alors sébastien beauvais à québec marie
vastel à ottawa michel ces objets à
montréal messieurs dames
bonsoir à vous bof accompagnerez ça on
parle on de cette crise ça commençait à
val d'or on viens de l'entendre ya des
témoignages l'ont été sur la côte nord
il y en a eu aussi ailleurs
sébastien à québec quand le premier
ministre finalement à dire en fin de
journée je vais rencontrer les chefs
autochtones sa baisse la pression selon
vous savez certainement l'impression est
finalement philippe clay avait
probablement pas vraiment un choix
d'accepter enfin pas d'accepter la
sommation que le lui avait transmise
jusqu'à le chef innu mais bien
l'invitation transmise aujourd'hui par
lettre pour une rencontre le 4 novembre
prochain lors de nation à nation on se
consulte on a des échanges et c'est dans
cet esprit là probablement que monsieur
couillard d'aborder la rencontre pour
s'enlever un peu de pression et pour
essayer de faire en sorte que on
désamorce un peu la tension qui existe
en ce moment je suis au j'ai en fait il
n'avait pas politiquement il y avait pas
beaucoup beaucoup d'avenue fallait
qu'ils disent oui enfin il n'y avait pas
le choix
puis son gouvernement continue encore à
fonctionner comme si ce n'est pas
vraiment eu les responsables de cette
crise là suis calé au sortir de la
période des questions aujourd'hui on à
divers qui est responsable de ça y'a 10
dans l'ordre la les communautés
j'imagine qu'ils voulaient dire les
communautés autochtones
le gouvernement fédéral puis oh oui nous
aussi on a une responsabilité c'est
d'abord une affaire de discipline
policière cette histoire là je sais qu
il ya plein d'autres aboutissants du
tenant et aboutissant dans une histoire
comme celle-là mais c'est d'abord et
avant tout une affaire de discipline
policière ça concerne au premier chef le
gouvernement du québec
il faut arrêter de dire à de sa faute la
loi sur les indiens puis vous propre
tête voir si leur faible de justin
trudeau pourrait pas nous aider lance un
moment donné il faut prendre ses
responsabilités pis là dedans c'est
celle là c'est la responsabilité du
monde que m marie vastel à tahoua
j'imagine on prend des notes
actuellement parce que le grand défi de
justin trudeau ça sera décrire le mandat
de sa commission
ça peut être très très large des comores
comment fera t-il ça d'après vous c'est
dur à dire je pense que lui même ne le
sait pas encore ça fait une chose de
plus s'ajoute à son agenda
déjà pas mal chargé mais je suis
d'accord avec michel que c'est pas qu'un
problème autochtone et je trouve ça
curieux de voir monsieur couillard un
peu s'en laver les mains en renvoyant la
balle à ottawa en martelant que cette
juridiction fédérale
parce que je suis tout à fait d'accord
dans cette lettre qui est sortie qui
avait été écrite à la scu et aux trois
ministres
la dame du comité d'amitié autochtone
disait que par l'aide de plusieurs
coques de lassitude générale vous et
aidez de culte mrc de plusieurs
personnes vulnérables dont plusieurs
femmes autochtones donc on semble
indiquer qu'il ya quand même d'autres
victimes dans ces histoires là est
peut-être qu'il faudrait une remise en
question plus large sur cette relation
de la police avec des des personnes plus
vulnérables qui ne sont semble-t-il pas
écouté
- respecter - entendu quand elle porte
plainte on dirait qu'il y avait des
allégations partout à val d'or mais
personne ne les avait vraiment tendu
comme quand on se fait à la police et au
gouvernement donc je trouve curieux qui
a eu aucune remise en question au niveau
provincial
mais sur la réaction de monsieur
couillard je pense qu'effectivement il
avait fait le choix ici à ottawa on se
souvient très bien d'un certain
mouvement appelé adorno morts monsieur
un peu les a ignorés pendant des
semaines ils ne sont jamais partis les
manifestations sont devenues de plus en
plus grande
les rues à tahoua la rue principale
devant le parlement étaient fermées
jusqu'à ce que mesure à un peu acceptent
de s'asseoir avec eux et avec le
gouverneur général parce que là aussi il
y avait un élément crise déclencheur qui
étaient les situations de logements dans
les communautés autochtones et donc je
pense que si monsieur coué ans ne
faisait rien tout ce ça n'aurait fait
que continuer à bouillir à court terme
si bas c'est à cette enquête qui
on le répète c'est la responsabilité
maintenant de la police de montréal est
un observateur ce qu'il ait pas de
nommer on n'a pas de sens dont on
connaît pas son identité encore donc on
doit chercher partout soit un ex-juge ou
quelqu'un de crédible qui pourrait par
sa personnalité assurer les gens que
cette enquête là va être indépendante à
c'est ça qui est compliqué là se dire
comment on fait pour retracer pied des
vieux cas là dedans comment fait on pour
aller retrouver les témoins faire en
sorte qu'il n'a pas peur de parler etc
oui et dans l'âme la suit la chronologie
et chose c'est quand même un peu
particulier monsieur couillard annonce
en chambre qui va y avoir un observateur
qui sera nommé pour accompagner le spvm
en général quand le premier ministre
fait ce genre d'annoncé cela c'est que
il sait déjà c'est qui les contacts ont
déjà été faits et la personne est
pratiquement dans l'antichambre de
l'assemblée nationale prête à sortir de
la chambre avec le premier ministre et
parler aux journalistes
éventuellement dans ce cas ci ça fait
presque 48 heures que monsieur couillard
l'annoncé enfin ça fait vingt-quatre
heures il annoncé hier en début de
journée et on sait toujours pas qui se
sera en lice que c'est une idée qui a
surgi comme ça le matin au déjeuner et
que monsieur client l'a servi à
l'assemblée nationale pour essayer
d'apaiser les tensions
on peut se poser la question dans la
mesure où on connaît toujours pas
l'identité de cette personne très bien
et en tout cas ce qui est sûr
marie-vincent elle a tabassé que c'était
un engagement très clair de justin
trudeau mais là il ne pourra pas tardé
il a il faudra que rapidement il ya une
opération qui se déploie d'ottawa
pendant qu'il ya une opération en tout
cas sur ses collègues policiers à val
d'or ça c'est une évidence qui continue
oui sauf que ce comité là qui où cette
commission d'enquêté qui sera mise sur
pied c'est sûr que ces travaux vont
s'échelonner sur un long moment
pis essais indépendants de ces enquêtes
policières donc effectivement je pense
qu'il va falloir qu'ils envoient un
signal assez rapidement il va avoir des
attentes à cet effet là dans la
plateforme libérale on parlait seulement
2 sans délai on donnait pas de
d'échéancier donc il faudra voir à
quelle vitesse tout se met en branle
mais c'est sûr que ça va être un
processus de longue haleine et je pense
pas qu'on ait
il ya la conclusion de cette commission
denquête l'a rapidement ou de sites aux
noms peas et puis c'est complexe faut
quand même le dire on change de sujet
messieurs dames
monsieur coderre qui a reçu la nouvelle
qui est pas étonnant mais la ministre
l'environnement qui lui restent cois
quelques jours comme les environnements
le savez vous c'est pas moi qui va
décider de mettre 6 milliards 8
milliards d'aud usées dans le fleuve de
montréal michel ses esprits tonale ce
pas étonnant mais c'est quand même la
mère de tous les cadeaux de départ dit
rob vous savez vous je m'en lave et les
mails jeu j'ai professeurs des raisons
électorales savez-vous mais ça ça donne
qu'un changement de gouvernement
c'est un peu trop transparent merci et
ça ça passe pas très bien la route mais
enfin c'est l'ironie suprême c'est que
c'est probablement ça va ça semble se
dessiner comme ça un minus montréal est
à dire stéphane guillon qui dont la
première décision va être choix de
déverser de toutes sortes de
cochonneries dans le fleuve
saint-laurent soit de faire dépenser
selon les deux millions à la ville de
montréal pour ne pas le faire alors
c'est pas très agréable mais c'est le
gouvernement conservateur qu'ils soient
blancs mais de ce qu'ils se targuait
d'être nous là ils font pas des
décisions difficiles les jo on en prend
des décisions difficiles
bon ben ça c'est pas ça c'est pas allé
jusqu'à la fin du mandat faut croire
ouais marie vastel michel parent de
stéphane dion qui me suis dit on aime
bien lire les dossiers être méticuleux
ses terres en le connaît peut-être qu'il
va dire non peut-être qu'il va dire non
il doit commencer à y penser à l'heure
où on se parle mais en même temps je
pense que la ministre aglukkaq 2 1 elle
n'est pas connue à tort comme étant une
ministre qui prend énormément de
décision qui parle particulièrement
beaucoup donc ça ne m'étonne pas
beaucoup mais en plus je pense que comme
vous dites on va voir un ministre dans
une semaine
ça serait allée vers souci un peu mal vu
qu'elle prenne une décision à la place
d'un gouvernement qui a été élue je
serais encore en place théoriquement mai
mais il ya quand même quelqu'un d'autre
qui a été un gouvernement qui a été élu
à sa place donc dans cette période de
flottement je pense que ça a été
difficile de décider quoi que ce soit
monsieur coderre avait l'air de dire que
de toute façon si on entendait trop
longtemps ce sera reporté d'un an donc
peut-être que le studio aura amplement
le temps de lire tous ces dossiers
sébastien là dessus le gouverneur du
québec le ministère de l'environnement
mr tel ministre l'environnement il ya
que ça se fasse peut-être qu'on passe à
autre chose la wii a tourné la page a dû
parce que monsieur airtel a été sur le
grill
mais quand les conseils dos il a été
chaud il l'était encore parce qu'on se
pose des questions aussi sur la façon
d'un gouvernement du québec gérer cette
affaire là moi je pense que si c'était
pas une vie ont dit non à denis coderre
va passer un coup de fil à justin
trudeau je pense qu'il a une ligne
directe monsieur coderre avec justin
trudeau
ils ont l'air de bien s'entendre les
deux et puis je reprend l'idée est de
michel c'est absolument ironique que
l'une des premières décisions du nouveau
ministre de l'environnement ce sera ce
sera peut-être de rejeter des eaux usées
alors que monsieur trudeau veut donner
l'impression que le gouvernement du
canada
le canada est de retour parmi les bons
échos liés aux changements climatiques
en prévision du sommet de paris au début
de décembre
il ya une certaine ironie dans les
premières décisions que le nouveau
ministre de l'environnement va devoir
prendre je m'excuse ans par des
changements climatiques mais il faut
dire aussi que ça c'est ailleurs dans
d'autres villes des déversements groupe
et que je sais pas trop où on les
déverse son lait déversé pas là donc je
comprends l'ironie mais en même temps il
ya moyen de bouillon le maire a essayé
m'arrive à celle de relativiser tout ça
depuis des semaines ya pas beaucoup
réussi parce que l'image est restée huit
milliards d'autres aient usé qui sortent
des égouts donc sa frappe l'imaginaire
mais voilà je veux entendre celle ci
auger on avait ce dossier hier d'une
école du plateau à montréal qui a fermé
sa bibliothèque scolaire compression la
technicienne la bibliothèque est partie
compression donc au mois de juin dernier
et ce sont des bénévoles de l'église du
plateau une église chrétienne ici ton
moderne qui se sont engagés à faire
revivre cette bibliothèque
ça pose des questions quand même chaîne
ça pose de grosses crises sur celui que
je connais bien moi mes deux fils ont
étudié la et l'ironie c'est que à
l'époque c'est plus comme ça maintenant
de toute évidence le projet particulier
de l'école c'est la lecture on valoriser
la lecture et avaient tous sont deux
programmes bras courage et jade à dire
alors resoumis raison pour laquelle mes
fesses voulait
l'or est imaginé la première chose qu'on
a faite c'est de fermer les
bibliothèques mais cela dit ce qui
marche pas dans cette histoire c'est que
lorsqu'on demande à des bénévoles de
faire quelque chose de dire si des
bénévoles
si on a de plusieurs groupes religieux
qui vient de savoir s'il y en a 80 d'un
groupe religieux qui débarque dans
l'école c'est peut-être pas trop on peut
présumer que la 66e 70e alors on peut
peut-être présumer que c'est patent du
bénévolat que du prosélytisme affaire
c'est une question qu'on peut poser
légitimement alors c'est ça qui est un
peu fatigué non je suis auger marie
vastel sébastien mercier à vous trois
c'est toujours un plaisir
à bientôt au revoir